[Musique]
fusion intercommunalités c'est le thème
de ce dernier rendez vous sur tv 78 à
l'occasion de l'université des maires
des yvelines 2018 à port-marly autour de
cette table à présent jean michel
fourgous bonjour président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines émerger
goncourt pauline tessier bonjour vous
êtes conseiller municipal de l'étang la
ville et puis à vos côtés également
conseiller municipal mais à rocquencourt
patrick espinasse bonjour aussi
bonjour bonjour à tous les deux je vais
commencer avec vous jean michel fourgous
maire d'elancourt président de 50 ans
est ce qu'aujourd'hui une commune ne
peut survivre qu'au sein d'une
intercommunalité il faut mutualiser les
moyens une commune seule ce n'est pas
possible
payer une réalité avant tout économique
je sais que les français
n'aime pas trop économie il adore
dhainaut d'autres mots mais là la
première réalité d'un maire c'est quand
même d'équilibré il doit financer des
crèches des écoles la voirie les seniors
la sécurité donc
donc voilà c'est pas c'est pas c'est
très sérieux en fait le la mission d'un
maire et quand on lui baisse de 20% son
budget ce qui est quand même ce qui se
passe
même 2% déjà c'est ya pas deux ils ont
pas de coffre dans l'est dans leurs
bureaux les maires donc cesser c'est
très grave
on se rend pas compte que quand plus est
les premiers investisseurs des
faussaires que à chaque fois qu'on
baisse les budgets des collectivités
locales ont fait plonger de jeu
donc la croissance et s'est détruit
l'emploi marchand des boîtes qui courait
du travail et qu'ils ne travailleront
pas donc faut bien voir que aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui comprend pas l'économie ça
devient quasiment dangereux de donner
des responsabilités dans la situation
économique de la france avait vu le taux
de le taux de croissance de 0,4 mais
snes et tout ça fait très peur aux
collectivités parce qu'ils savent que
derrière il y aura donc moins de
recettes sur à moins de pib de
croissance pour les tailles donc sûrs à
moindre coût l'erreur des recettes qui
manqueront est à nouveau l'état pour
équilibrer ses comptes
il s'en prendra voilà des gens qui
travaillent bien parce que les
collectivités elles font un travail mais
mes merveilleux je veux dire que c'est
pas parce que je suis un fils avant donc
bien sûr devant cette situation de crise
économique majeure je dis bien majeur
c'est pas une plaisanterie ce qui se
passe
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qu on fait
entre nous on se regarde avec notre
voisin ont dit bon est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas partager j'ai pas le fonctionnement
des ordures ménagères le fonctionnement
du traitement de l'eau le fonctionnement
c'est déjà un peu le cas d'ailleurs mais
maintenant des syndicats mais optimiser
les mots aujourd'hui c'est optimiser ses
c'est mutualisé s'est rassemblée alors
c'est facile à dire un micro mais après
gérer les hommes qui appartenaient des
structures différentes avec des cultes
aux différentes moi je le vis au travers
de deux de saint quentin
moi j'ai hésité à prendre ce poste parce
que si vous y allez vous devez moi j'ai
quand même assez je suis un élu de
droite je m'assume là dessus sans
complexe 1 je pense que oui bien il ya
quand même un personne n'est parfait
mais il ya un bon sens auch pas il ya
une ré un réalisme économique de chez
les gens de droite bon que les jeunes
beauchesne souvent plus parler des
j'irai des idées avec des modélisateurs
les mots moi je veux l'entreprise dans
les fêtes et réalité résultat là donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile surtout
en france où il y avait quelques fois
même si aussi à gauche le modernisme et
il y avait foule dire aussi bon c'est un
peu évolué aussi mais il ya quand même
un choc encore culturels ont besoin
accepter de présider
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça veut dire
il faut donner des vice-présidences à
tout le monde leur faut pas y aller donc
à ce moment-là j'ai moi j'ai mis de
l'eau dans mon vin comme on est et puis
bon ben voila j'ai mis tout le monde
autour de la table avec des différences
et mais c'est une autre façon de manager
vous pouvez pas dire
qu'un peu de vous poser aussi après une
fois que c'est super structures existent
ces intercommunalités ou alors les
groupements de communes on va venir tout
à l'heure sk pas un risque pour les lui
pour le maire de perdre aussi du pouvoir
décisionnaire 6 mai à partir du moment
où vous retire 20 % de votre budget il
faut trouver une solution parce que le
maire il obligeait tous une solution lui
il a pas le choix
les solutions c'est soit il supprime une
crèche une école soit il baisse la
qualité de certaines prestations de
service public
il n'y a pas autre chose il veut même
pas s'endetter parce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça la comptabilité à la
m14 comme on dit donc il n'a pas le
choix et c'est vraiment dire c'est pas
gentil gentil vers ce qu'on fait aux
collectivités qui joue le jeu c'est pas
les collectivités qui abuse vraiment de
quoi que ce soit c'est pas parce qu'il
ya oui il ya toujours 1% ou 2% 3 pour
son excès mais c'est pas les dans les
collectivités qu'on devrait taper donc
on est obligé de se mettre tous ensemble
et d'optimiser et de moi-même avec
maurepas on a on a mis une école en
commun entre la ville des nominés colle
encore à l'intercommunalité de vie voilà
un symbole a dit m
et c'est que le début parce qu'ici quand
tu ne te taper dessus comme ça oui on va
être obligé de alors maintenant votre
question sur est ce que les
les lmr hier fallait que moi communes
perdent un peu de d'autonomie dans
l'acteur combat oui oui on va pas se
cacher les choses
moi je suis de côté je le vois bien sûr
mais en même temps il faut être
intelligent il serait qu'il ya débat sur
sûr je sais pas sur certains travaux qui
sont plus faciles à faire de façon en
proximité que par l'interco c'est un
débat mais souvent les maires et des
élus qui votent des lois ils sont pas
tous aujourd'hui on a cassé les députés
verts c'est une vraie bêtise parce que
vous l'aimez dit plus mais il avait les
pires lingue l'aise quand il veut
t'aider loi ne se faisait plus de lien
donc eh ben on veut on veut être des
choses pour les pour les communes qui
n'ont pu de réalité c'est vrai que c'est
une vraie souffrance mais on essaye de
gérer ça le plus intelligemment possible
voilà c'est ça se passe pas que ça se
passe plutôt bien fait un bond
quelquefois ça se passe mal mais je sais
c'est très c'est très difficile c'est un
exercice très difficile on va revenir à
saint quentin en yvelines pauline
teyssier je me tourne vers vous ont
parlé de votre commune maintenant
conseillère municipale à l'étang la
ville votre commune qui a décidé de ne
pas rejoindre finalement une nouvelle
création avec avec saint germain en laye
c'est exact vous le regrettez vous le
déplorez personnel je n'avais pas suivi
sur sept projets parce que pour un petit
peu pour des raisons qui étaient
évoquées ici à savoir où des pins on a
souhaité souhaité nous présenter
davantage de faire partie d'une grande
ville c'était avec faut que marie magnet
saint germain en laye et connaissons et
ont rencontré beaucoup de maires
le disco à peu près pareil c'est à dire
de plus en plus les grandes villes sont
plus en souffrance cas les limite les
petites villes
le petite ville on peut faire il ya
toujours des gens près rendent des
services qui veut dire qu'on peut faire
des activités de choses ensemble et un
moindre coût' se dire il ya beaucoup de
bénévolat partir du moment que vous
faites partie d'une grande ville que
vous ai fait partie d'un comité
d'agglomération
il ya plus cette notion là la proche de
risque à quelque chose de ta taille
humaine on va dire voilà enfin ce nom
rester à taille humaine c'était plus
intéressant
il faut dire qu'à l'étang la ville on
avait deux choses qui qui après sortie
tout de suite qu'on n'avait pas une
continuité de territoire que à travers
mareil marly
alors pour fusionner il faut avoir
continué de territoire ci contient
mareil marly voter compte ce qui était
le cas de cette fusion deux fils ont été
exclus de la fusion en plus ça on avait
le problème de la sru
on avait pensé qu'on se fusionneront
avec saint germain mais on allait
pouvoir d'y verser en partie de notre
sérieux sur saint germain en laye pascal
est ton avis il n'y a aucun terrain à
vendre
donc si difficile de construire des
des logements sociaux si on n'a pas de
dire on avait espéré en faisant partie
de cette fusion pouvoir peut-être
acheter quelques terrains dont les
autres communes en vue de construire des
logements sociaux est pas prendre notre
part dans sept ans dans cette loi qu'ils
étaient
votée il ya dans la loi matin parlant du
cas du concours le chesnay à présent on
parle de cette question un
d'intercommunalité de fusion quel avenir
pour ces différentes communes pour le
cadre où concourt le chesnay la fusion
ou la création d'une nouvelle commune a
été entérinée il ya quelques jours par
les deux conseils municipaux
oui vous accueillez ça d'un oeil
bienveillant tout à fait faut savoir que
dans l'est dans les conseils municipaux
du qui ont eu lieu le 18 juin parce que
la loi oblige que les deux conseils
municipaux aient lieu le même jour et en
même temps les votes ont fait ou qui ont
été émis de 18 juin sont exactement ceux
qui ont été émis l'a dit avant-hier soir
donc bon je crois coach est né il ya
deux élus de l'opposition et six
nouveaux concours il ya eu une
abstention le projet de réunir les deux
communes en fait est que j'irai une
poursuite de l'histoire parce qu'en fait
art concours
il est déjà le premier fait c'est que
l'on a le même code postal que je
chesnais pour la bonne raison c'est que
nous n'avons pas de bureau de poste
orbital
une agence postale en en mairie que nous
n'avons pas d'église les églises en sur
le chesnay pardon que nous n'avons pas
de cimetière donc nous payons une
quote-part ce qui est tout à fait
logique a enchaîné pour pouvoir enterrer
nos anciens d'euros concours que nous
avons que le maire de rocquencourt là je
parle sous sa gouverne parce que c'est
ce qui l'a clairement exprimé en conseil
municipal qui donc à une réunion comme
outil république que c'est le maire
d'euros concours qui est allé voir
monsieur brio le maire du chesnay pour
aborder le sujet d'une création d'une
nouvelle commune donc si vous voulez
c'était pas la grande commune qui
absorbe la petite c'était vraiment un
projet conjoint des deux mers nous avons
un certain nombre de d'activités
municipale scolaire notamment parce que
nous avons un gros concours une école
maternelle d'une école élémentaire
nous n'avons pas de collège nous n'avons
pas de lycée donc les jeunes rocancourt
toi quand ils sont en âge de rentrée en
6e vont au chesnay systématiquement et
ensuite le soin se fait suivant le pas
le la direction je dirais de lycée se
fait suivant le choix académique de du
jeune ou ce qui lui est conseillé soit
le chesnay soit versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi s'est
posé cette question en tout cas les
communes qui sont à l'intérieur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de fusion de
création de nouvelles communes je
pensais à coignières et à maurepas où
les discussions ont eu lieu ça a été
assez mal accueilli par une partie de la
population aujourd'hui la situation est
même compliqué pour coignières mais est
aussi d'autres raisons qui est qui
rentrent en ligne de compte et grands un
nouveau un nouveau maire qui sera
désigné les électeurs sont appelés aux
urnes à coignières le 25 novembre
cette idée de fusion de communes
coignard maurepas vous l'avez regardé
comment de calais y est on a pas mieux
trouver que l'instant que la démocratie
c'est pas un système parfait mais c'est
moins pire ce que si l'on dit donc voilà
tous adoptés ça mais j'irai moi je crois
que l'opposition à akwaya hinault donc
une majorité d'opposition l'opposition à
coignières où les gens qui avaient des
jeux d'opposition ou des jeux de pouvoir
ou un ou des égouts etc
hong kong plongeait sur sur ce dossier
de la fusion coignières à maurepas
pour entre guillemets faut se le dire
pour exploiter je dirais
l'incompréhension économique parce que
nous nos électeurs faut le dire
notamment france 1
l'incompréhension des bienfaits
économiques puisque l'objectif c'est
bien sûr de faire face à l' équilibre
budgétaire pourquoi on fusionne il est
aussi question de s'affoler mais ça nos
électeurs ne le comprennent pas alors
oui ils réfléchissent oui quel est le
nom de la ville qui va être sur la
fusion à ce que c'est le voisin ce que
c'est nous c'est donc ils ont réfléchi
hauteur ça et puis bon yann opposant kkk
habilement bien sûr agité perte
d'autonomie perte d'identité pertes mais
là ça touche les gens comme bon ce
qu'est ce qui est dommage c'est que
c'est qu'on est bien éloignée ou sais
c'est que c'est comme isf on a vendu y
est cependant je pas 30 ans en france
ces gens qui sont persuadés que c'est
comme robin des bois on appris aux
riches à donner aux pauvres
c'est faux c'est totalement faux ça
rapporte et 100 milliards à l'état en
est depuis 30 ans peu de temps en temps
et ça fait fuir 600 milliards mais voilà
mais les gens n'ont pas de culture
économique qui sont quand il y aura eu
sa peau mais c'est une catastrophe tous
les pays au monde sont tous se
débarrasser de ça quand ils ont vu les
dégâts mais c'est pareil là vous êtes
devant une situation ils vont ils ont
pas vu parce que bien entendu l'opposant
kamil le souk non non bien sûr entre les
deux communes s'est dit je vais en tirer
un profit je veux dire je défends ma
commune pas du tout nîmes et sa commune
en difficulté économique c'est tout et
des difficultés économiques servent ou
baisser derrière les services publics
vous me fermer une crèche une école et
ksar donc mais dans les débats alors
c'est le débat démocratique mais il
faudrait fixer une règle je ferai
peut-être que la presse peut peut-être
joué un rôle aussi d'être dans l'ancien
mais de rappeler quand même que au delà
de vous êtes beau vous n'êtes pas beau
vous êtes diplômés pas diplômés vous
êtes si vous êtes ça bon il ya quand
même des réalités de résultats bien
entendu que les gens on fusionne parce
qu'aujourd'hui on vit on vient malheurs
économiques faut quand même le dire les
causes y avait pensé à une fusion pour
la ville et l'encours par exemple oui
avec d'autres communes a été évoqué
c'est évoquer mon s'est dit bon après
2020 on verra ça
pour l'instant et puis comme je suis
devenu président de l'agglo ou en
s'assoyant moi j'essaie du travail sur
les douze maintenant d'optimiser un peu
des moyens plus que plus que fusions de
communes mais je respecte et je rappelle
qu'il ya plus de 1000 communes qui sont
en fusion de communes c'est pas
extraordinaire passé c'est une réalité
c'est un besoin mais c'est pour ça que
lorsque des élus vont exciter l'opinion
a joué sur l'identité et c'est bon c'est
pas un service c'est pas c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien de faire ça mais bon
voilà démocratie vous devez c'est tout
le monde s'exprimer et et tout cas je
pense que cette fusion a été léchée a
échoué du fait qu' il ya eu ce jeu
pervers avec les mauvais les mots les
mots dans le monde qui sont plus forts
que les fesses et c'est grave ça moi je
les vois les faits passe avant les mômes
et ben voilà les mots bien un peu
affective et émotionnelle
dramatisant caricaturant ça plus
d'impact qu'un qu'une réalité économique
voilà mais c'est la réalité économique
justement est-ce qu'il y aura une
réalité économique entre au concours et
le chesnay pour pour les habitants pour
le quotidien pour les ressources de vos
communes alors au niveau de la commune
il ya deux actifs il ya deux impératifs
économiques qui sont primordiaux
quiconque y sont impactés par la loi sru
puisque nous sommes un petit peu dans le
même cas que le temps la ville à savoir
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus de
terrains pour construire des logements
sociaux d'où venons de terminer à un
énorme programme de logements sociaux
sur la zac donc le vieux au concours
nous sommes en négociation également à
ventes en cours de travaux plus
exactement avec les architectes des
bâtiments de france pour réhabiliter de
gendarmerie quitte en bordure de la
plaque de versailles donc on a quand
même des contraintes techniques et c'est
ce dossier est quand même en cours
depuis quelques années maintenant et
donc le le préfet a mis sous tutelle
quand même le maire du chesnay et le
maire d'euros concours pour non respect
des engagements liés à la loi sru
le fait de créer cette nouvelle commune
on repart ex nihilo puisqu'on est une
commune qui ne qui n'aura jamais existé
et donc on part avec une une franchise
de 5 ans je crois ces cinq ans sans sans
taxes liées à la loi sru puisque nous
n'avons pas de dj historique sur le
recaser rôle exactement
de plus le fait de regrouper les deux
communes aussi une autre incidence
économique sur le plan des des pénalités
puisque pendant trois 3 ans ne devront
plus de pénalités par pour non respect
de l'engagement des fal la loi et
concernant les 25 % de logements sociaux
et donc qu'on a jusqu'à 2022 pour
constituer une cagnotte pour faire face
à cette à cet aléa qui n'est pas un aléa
qui sait qu'il sera une certitude
et deuxièmement on a une prime de touche
nos primes de la part de bercy
concernant le fait de la création de la
nouvelle commune
donc économiquement c'est effectivement
ce sont des éléments qui ne sont pas
neutres dans la décision
les autres éléments économiques
concernant l'hérault concours toit et
les chesnaysiens sont le fait de pouvoir
utiliser au même tes même titré au même
tarif que les chesnaysiens la piscine de
mutualiser le centre aéré qu'on a déjà
mutualiser la cuisine de l'école
élémentaire où on s'aperçoit qu'on gagne
aussi en qualité et en est en cours donc
c'est cher c'est ça c'est tout à fait
pour rejoindre le le langage du duc du
président de la communauté
d'agglomération on a tout à gagner dans
la mesure où effectivement la priorité
étant quand même lié au fait que les
deux communes veille de faire et ne soit
pas de ne pas imposer
du côté de l'étang la ville la porte est
fermée à une éventuelle je voulais quand
même préciser que les gens de l'étang
david n'était pas contraint une fusion
c'était l'idée même que il y avait pas
de projet de territoire c'est à dire les
gens de l'étang la vie ne se sentait pas
assez proche de celle de saint chemin
plus j'veux dire y avait beaucoup de
gens qui étaient dans une position qui
aurait souhaité faire une fusion avec
marc meslois parce que nous partageons
précisément un collège on ne se sent pas
un petite commune à côté de celui de
marly le roy on sent continuité non pas
seulement de territoire mais d'idées
d'utilisation de commerce ont partagé
une piscine mais on a un collège donc un
marais droit et à mener c est donc le
genre vont facilement même au marché aux
grandes supermarché de centre-ville
il ne comprenait pas ces projets le
problème de les serrures et se serait
posé de toute façon avec marley le roi
mais déjà on avait un projet commun et
souvent quand on parle de fusion il faut
surtout pas parler d'abord d'argent il
faut vraiment avoir un projet après
l'argent se règlent petit à petit après
on a même 12 ans pour
sa ligne et les uns avec les autres donc
largement de temps pour régler ce
problème et après tout c'est quelque
chose qui peut se faire dans sur le long
terme est que ça ne vraiment ça ne pose
pas de problème mais pas con pour les
gens ce qui posait des problèmes
s'étaient pas avoir un projet de
territoire où ils se sentent et inclut
la vérité sur ce voile à l'identité est
resté dans la question à poser avant de
conclure cette émission avoue
jean-michel fourgous on parlait dé
fusion des intercommunalités des places
des communes
je prends l'exemple de saint quentin en
yvelines est ce que les
intercommunalités doivent s'élargir
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
travailler dessus
non nous on est dans un cas particulier
puisque on est dans un réseau puissant
on est
comme vous on en europe
on est dans l'île de france qui est
l'agent la plus puissante de
d'europe on est dans les îles in qui est
quand même un département riche mêlant
paris-saclay qu'est le
premier réservoir de cerveau et
technologique français et saint quentin
et le 2ème pib par habitant après paris
donc bien sûr d un réseau puissant donc
dans un réseau puissant communauté
d'agglomération on est un peu plus de
200 il ya plus de 200 communes de
tableaux communauté urbaine vous êtes
moins de 20 donc c'est vrai que vous
existez plus
dans un réseau de 20 que dans un réseau
de 200 et c'est vrai qu'on a pris une
taille aujourd'hui en puissance
économique qui fait qu'on est une
immense internationaux c'est ce que la
ryder cup on a été cité un milliard de
fois par équipes plus d'un milliard de
fois enfin imaginer la campagne de com'
n'ayant cessé 100 millions quasiment du
coucou n'a pas payé donc bien sûr que on
est dans un réseau ou à ce niveau là il
faut qu'on monte en communauté urbaine
pour pouvoir mieux profiter des moyens
européens et de france qui était un
point c'est tout maintenant ça change
pas grand chose que 50 est déjà très
mutualisé parce que après vous avez le
degré de mutualisation par exemple
versailles grand parc et très peu
mutualisés
parce que c'est chaud plus disons fait
bon et nous on est on est plus de 50% de
l'activité des communes et mutualisées
dans l'interco donc et on est donc très
proche de comédien ben voila mais
maintenant si ça se fait alors si ça
c'est effectivement on a 8 millions de
moins de 2 de prélèvement donc c'est
quand même pas mal en ce moment
et en plus on augmente notre audience
pour obtenir des subventions pour rose
pour diffuser nos communes alentour pour
éventuellement agrandir cette
agglomération et wii puis dernier mot
nous on a une grosse trouille entre
guillemets c'est l' annonce de la baisse
de la taxe
ça va de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation de dire mme aucun élan
courtois est venu me voir pour me dire
monsieur le maire est ce qu'on peut
supporter les habitations à personne ne
faut pas toucher un impôt qui est
accepté faut vraiment ne pas avoir
d'expérience politique économique des
collectivités pour sortir d'un bêtise
pareille une erreur vraiment ça c'est
pour vendre un du clientélisme parce que
vendre avant les élections effectivement
vous
c'est un feeling en sable moi je
conseille d'ailleurs aux présidents de
reculer très vite là dessus parce que
c'est un set explosif ça ya des communes
qui vivent à pas 80% de la taxe
d'habitation mois ils encourent c'est
une vingtaine de bourses en donc mais
mais mais c'est très dur pour moi mais
une commune qui à près de 80% mais
comment vous allez alors ils vont
augmenter la taxe foncière mais il vous
rendez compte en ce moment avec social
est déjà trop élevé pincez il faut qu'il
faut cru il faut reculer là-dessus parce
que là là ça va être un peu plus
conflictuel entre l'état et les
collectivités et or l'état besoins des
collectifs peut pas vivre tout seul
c'est moi le chef non ça ça marche pas
comme ça la vie démocratique politique
en france ne marche pas comme ça il faut
faire évoluer en tout cas moi voilà ce
que les les enseignements c'est plutôt
ça se passe bien en tout cas à saint
quentin
on a fait tous ces efforts la gauche la
droite des communes plus rurales et
périurbaines c'est différent quand vous
fait traîner commune plutôt urbaine
plutôt rural bon ils sont pas les mêmes
vrai mais on a à peu près on n'est pas
prêt d'arriver à trouver une règle du
jeu
on s'entend vient de faire un séminaire
ce week-end à imola il n'y a pas eu
c'est une fois là tout le monde devient
constructif maintenant écoutez c'est
bien
positif écoutez vous voilà je me plains
de rien on va terminer cette émission
sur cette note positive
voilà deux ans mais a dit écoutez on
optimise et de mutualiser rassembler
c'est des mots très positif maintenant
attention derrière gérer les facteurs
humains
les élus ils font un travail formidable
en même temps leurs petites crises d'égo
temps quand vous quand vous les faites
quand vous rassembler plusieurs communes
oui effectivement il ya un peu plus de
rivalité bon faut chercher enfin un
manager un maire c'est quand même
manager donc c'est bien ouais
maire-adjoint c'est pareil bon voilà
mais mes ccc positif mais attention faut
pas aller plus loin il faut pas toucher
à la taxe d'habitation là c'est vraiment
mon avis une erreur politique qui
montrerait que les gens qui sont alors à
l'origine de çà ne connaissent
strictement rien de la vie politique
française notamment des collectivités
locales et là ce serait une grave erreur
merci beaucoup à vous trois mâts c'est
d'avoir participé à cette émission
c'était la dernière de cette journée
spéciale umih une hier c'étaient des
mairies sur tv 78 merci aux équipes
techniques qui ont participé à
l'élaboration de cette émission toutes
les émissions tout au long de cette
journée sont à revoir sur notre site
internet et puis sur notre antenne
antenne aussi régulièrement merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis bonne fin de
journée
on
[Musique]